oh it's about time
it's totally clock right time this is
what I'm really here for if we're not
getting Beyond Good and Evil 2 which
apparently went on Oh Splinter Cell this
is what I wanted to see based on that
that post up I haven't been excited
about far cry 4 ages I loved 3 you got
me with Gustavo Fring
this shot beautiful meal perfect but
useless
I'm also have something for you very
enter the idea that you play as the bad
guys villain maybe I mean bad guys son
the villains son do ruin a simple oh it
has four basic parts it looks so good
the shell which contains the explosive
his hands get nuts the handle obviously
can't please not gonna look like that so
good nothing about getting excited about
but this is a very good looking trail
whoa trouble up here at Sun breeze the
pin simply austere handle he's right I
should have listened mmm indeed I feel
like it's a sort of similar role he's
the same like cool calm collected guy no
I wonder where this is said I am El
Presidente
maybe Cuba which means that someday oh I
guess [ __ ] you should know places yes
and are people they do not know how to
be happy they are torn apart by opinions
noise indecision up let me get you
strangled by their own freedoms and even
if you have love in your heart you and
if you want what's best for them if you
only want to save them from themselves
time again this is nuts
oh Christ so we every do you say
actually Ubisoft in general believe we'd
be wrong they like touch on being
political sometimes but then never
actually do which means I feel like this
story is kind of always end up feeling a
little bit the same we're just like they
don't really give you anything to think
about most of the time cuz they're just
like they don't commit to anything they
dance around things they will also use
screams Tammy looks good call you easy
and monster if this is a [ __ ] are set in
like a really populated city like this
yes that would be you
so you tell me maybe it is set in a city
already cool obviously they can do that
I mean like unity was on at the time
amazing for the amount of people moving
in one city
while looks not there because our
country is like this grenade except it
has two basic parts our people
and new and you must clutch them nice
and died so try to make him like blow
out the protesters cuz that's pretty
[ __ ] up dude
I understand his point for the most part
[Music]
definitely back out up you understand
now
Wow all right yeah I'm into it whoo